the experience with the chest challenge
is very fun I had a great time doing it
on the incubator the geillis is felons
all the designers a great job and making
this work out so I'm really happy to see
what I bought but I've done also a my
another comic shop down the throat just
definitely influenced my design in a
sense of playing with the black and
white and then just intellectual thought
of it and the symbolism side of it I
discovered the parallel between the
history of the Queen speaks in the board
using and embodying the book and
offensive which is colliding here in
Maya Bazar a piece was inspired by the
print of the Queen and please and see
she has kind of like her armor on we can
see the shapes of the neckline and the
felt that we had laser-cut on but it
also a little kind of like feminine
touch here who really like pop Queen
Matilda feminine speakers I was
influenced by the night and the pond
they're like the two weakest people on
the chessboard but I wanted to make a
very strong look from our teeth so on
the sleeve you'll see elements of the
knife and the body of the dress is more
like a pawn today I wanted to make it
very fun very sexy very chic and very
feminine there is a war in the World Cup
qualifying Museum and it's full of
carved intricate ornate SS and there's
one on display this Park totally
exported cells and it has its court
itself in this plate and and so when I
saw that I was like that it's all now
it's time for the moment we've all been
waiting for the announcement of pins
winning designer this special designer
will receive a $10,000 scholarship the
winner of the pin
Challenge is autograph
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I want to thank Maurice my
grandmaster my cohort here you know
really speaking to these two worlds
colliding and the functionality and
class that we wanted to bring back to
the branding of chess I also I just want
to acknowledge the other prize designers
I mean the talent that was presented
today was exceptional and and they
deserved it a round of applause as well
[Applause]